bonjour à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public 90 minutes de débats
et de reportage 90 minutes avec nos
experts pour donner du sens à
l'actualité on se retrouve tous les
jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h et
voici le sommaire de ce 21 septembre
Vladimir Poutine mobilise 300000
réservistes annoncent l'organisation de
référendum dans les régions ukrainiennes
occupées et Brandi de nouveau la menace
nucléaire
chanter avec des armes nucléaires
doivent savoir que le vent peut aussi
tourner dans leur direction
faut-il vraiment craindre cette menace
ou au contraire voir dans ce discours un
signe de faiblesse de l'annuaire Poutine
et de son armée Raiponce dans deux
minutes et puis pour notre débat de
société vous le savez volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour on va
explorer le monde virtuel du metaves un
univers ou votre avatar peut vivre une
autre vie fantasmée et dépenser beaucoup
d'argent c'est là-dessus que mise Mark
Zuckerberg le patron de Facebook
rebaptisé méta mais à quoi ça sert le
metaves en avant nous vraiment besoin
n'est ce pas absurde de se lancer dans
une technologie numérique aussi
polluante on en débattra dans 45 minutes
mais d'abord donc les menaces de
Vladimir Poutine et les premières
réactions occidentales notamment celle
de Joe Biden avec Jérôme Rabier il n'a
pas encore prononcé le mot guerre mais
Vladimir Poutine franchit une nouvelle
étape dans ce qu'il appelle une
opération spéciale en Ukraine sa réponse
au contre-attaques ukrainiennes qui ont
fait reculer les forces russes et sans
précédent depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
il estime nécessaire de renforcer son
armée
pour protéger notre patrie sa
souveraineté et son intégrité
territoriale pour assurer la sécurité de
notre peuple et des populations des
territoires libérés j'estime nécessaire
de soutenir la proposition du ministère
de la Défense et de l'état-major général
de procéder à une mobilisation partielle
dans la Fédération de Russie
une mobilisation pour le moment partiel
et qui concernera 300 000 citoyens
russes ayant une expérience militaire à
immédiatement précisée le ministre de la
Défense russe une nécessité selon
Vladimir Poutine qui dénonce une volonté
de l'Occident de détruire la Russie en
utilisant l'Ukraine un scénario balayé
par le porte-parole de l'Union
européenne qui voit surtout un Ave de
faiblesse
c'est juste une autre preuve de Poutine
qu'il n'est pas intéressé par la paix
qu'il est intéressé par l'escalade de sa
guerre c'est aussi un autre signe de son
désarroi
le président réussit aussi promis
d'utiliser tous les moyens à sa
disposition si l'intégrité territoriale
du pays était menacé un chantage à
l'harmonucléaire dénoncer depuis l'ONU
par le président américain
juste aujourd'hui le président Poutine a
proféré des menaces nucléaires contre
l'Europe cela entre encore en
contradiction flagrante avec le Traité
de Non proliférations nucléaires
la quasi-totalité des capitales
européennes ont aussi dénoncé les
menaces du Kremlin Emmanuel Macron a lui
appelé la communauté internationale à
mettre le maximum de pression sur
Vladimir Poutine voilà c'est une fin
d'après-midi passionnante beaucoup de
réactions depuis notamment l'ONU
réaction diplomatique évidemment il y a
la situation militaire et il y a les
enjeux diplomatiques qu'on va décrypter
ensemble grâce à mes invités le général
Dominique trinquant bonsoir bienvenue
ancien chef de la mission militaire
française auprès de l'ONU Patricia
lemonnière bonsoir Patricia grand
porteur spécialiste en politique
internationale
j'accueille également à lazareva bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes rédactrice en chef
adjointe du journal Ukraine ski Tizian
d'ailleurs vous avez lancé une page en
français récemment de de ce journal et
Mathieu croissanto éditorialise
politique bonsoir Mathieu alors il y a
beaucoup d'éléments je commence par là
mobilisation des des 300000 réservistes
Dominique trinquant peut-être sur le
plan militaire qu'est-ce que ça change
est-ce qu'il peut rapidement les envoyer
sur le terrain question très concrète
pour décorer rapidement non il a
d'ailleurs lui-même expliqué qu'il
fallait continuer à les former avant de
les envoyer donc c'est une demi-usure on
sait que les nationalistes extrémist
russe demande la mobilisation tout de
suite pour enfin faire la guerre et lui
n'ose pas aller jusque là et donc il
prend une demi mesure mais ça marque à
la fois la difficulté des ressources
humaines de l'armée russe mais ça on le
sait depuis un petit moment et puis
l'échec de ce politique il a eu beau
annoncé il y a quelques jours que tout
se déroulait suivant le plan on voit
bien que ça dérouge pas suivant le plan
puisqu'il est obligé de prendre des
mesures complémentaires donc c'est
service c'est probablement des gens qui
sont plus près que les volontaires qui
ont été demandées depuis plusieurs
semaines dans toutes les républiques de
la fédération et qui n'arrivent pas
vraiment donc ce sont des gens qui sont
normalement formés qui devraient arriver
plus vite mais quand on voit comment
sont équipés les soldats qui combattent
aujourd'hui on a quelques doutes sur la
capacité d'équiper ceux qui arriveront
demain effectivement Patricia manière
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est c'est
en creux la faiblesse que ça révèle de
l'armée russe de ces difficultés sur le
terrain aujourd'hui oui de temps ce dont
il a besoin c'est des fantassins et je
suis pas sûr que ceux qui veulent
appeler soit des fantassins dans ce qui
est intéressant dans cette position
c'est que je crois que Vladimir Poutine
en quelque sorte était un peu dans un
coin cornaqué comme on dit parce qu'il a
de son côté il est dur du régime dont
vous faites allusion et qui eux
voulaient la guerre totale la
mobilisation parfaite etc ce dont il ne
voulait pas depuis le début il ne veut
pas de cette mobilisation et je pense
que la pression était à ce point forte
qu'il a dû leur donner quelque chose
donc c'est d'abord un discours à usage
interne je crois que c'est d'abord un
discours parce que je crois que la
menace des dure était suffisamment forte
suffisamment prégnante pour
que obligé de lâcher et donc il a lâché
d'une façon comme vous le dites très
modérée en quelque sorte bon maintenant
il va falloir quoi 300000 réservistes
1%, 5% de toutes de tout ce qui pouvait
faire s'il faisait la mobilisation
générale donc c'est pas grand chose en
tout cas ce sont des hommes qui qui
entouraient sont compétents voici
connaissent en matière militaire mais va
savoir si effectivement les techniciens
supérieures ceux qui sont électroniciens
etc voudront se rendre vous en servir
ceci dit la Douma vous avez vu à passer
une loi en disant que tous ceux qui ne
servaient pas étaient considérés comme
très très Russie alors ça c'est
intéressant effectivement à Lazare parce
que
c'est réserviste on a l'impression que
là on a eu beaucoup d'écho de de
d'informations dans cet après-midi ils
cherchent à échapper à la mobilisation
oui tout à fait et pas seulement les
réservistes j'ai vu que sur Google
aujourd'hui il y avait le plus grand
quantité de demande
qui correspondait à la recherche comment
quitter la Russie comment se cassait une
jambe comment se casser une bras comment
partir sans visa donc voilà le Google
trade a fait savoir Google donc c'est
vraiment les demandes les plus
importantes c'est statistiques tout à
fait tout à fait voilà
cette fois-ci c'est notre parce que
c'est pas l'information en provenance de
la Russie qui peut être un peu disons
d'oser et superviser par le pouvoir
russe il y a plus d'avion pour Dubaï je
crois et pour la Turquie c'est tout
plein
de bizarre il y a pas d'autres
destinations possibles c'est ça grosso
modo il y a une histoire de sémantique
aussi dans une trinquant le mot guerre
que je veux dire ne veut pas employer
c'est opération spéciale il l'a pas
employé non plus dans dans ce discours
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en déduire d'une
certaine façon employé alors pour
revenir sur le point du discours envers
la Russie quelque chose qui ne trompe
pas le discours était prévu pour va être
donné hier soir hier soir ça veut dire
la Russie à l'Est dort les États-Unis
sont réveillés ça a été fait ce matin et
là toute la Russie est réveillée alors
que les États-Unis dorment donc on voit
bien que le discours il est d'abord pour
la Russie ensuite dans la sémantique
c'était intéressant le petit extrait que
vous avez montré du président Poutine il
ne parle pas de la menace de l'arme
nucléaire par les Russes il dit c'est
vous qui menacez avec l'arme nucléaire
le vent pourrait tourner et ce sont nos
fantasmes à nous qui font qu'on dit en
permanence qui nous menace avec l'arme
nucléaire il fait bien attention de ne
pas le dire il a employé une fois je
crois tout à fait au début de la guerre
ça a changé radicalement puisqu'on sait
très bien que nous avons mis en posture
nucléaire aussi nos armements donc il a
changé depuis il en parle pas il accuse
toujours les autres et il menace d'une
escalade sans dire où est le plafond de
l'escalade on y reviendra sur la menace
nucléaire et comment nous on doit la
recevoir mais on peut aussi se demander
Mathieu si le discours du président
russe est une réponse alors ça c'est
notre prisme très français au discours
d'Emmanuel Macron mais on va je vous
poserai la question dans un instant mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est quand même
de d'analyser le discours de d'Emmanuel
Macron devant l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies donc c'était hier à New
York oui parce que c'est un discours qui
a surpris de nombreux observateurs par
sa tonalité d'habitude il faut le dire
quand même on s'ennuie à mourir dans les
monologues des chefs d'État à la tribune
des Nations Unies l'essentiel se joue
d'ailleurs plutôt en coulisses c'est
rarement à la tribune que ça se passe
mais cette fois-ci dans un discours de
32 minutes c'était deux fois le temps
qui lui était imparti le chef de l'État
a tout tapé du point sur son pupitre et
a voulu marquer les esprits par sa
fermeté
on écoute Emmanuel Macron
cause d'un nouvel impérialisme d'un
cynisme contemporain qui désagrège notre
ordre international sans lequel la paix
n'est possible
c'était pas forcément le son que
j'attendais et voilà
la tonalité la tonalité en fait le chef
de l'État s'en est pris à plusieurs
reprises l'attitude de la Russie
coupable à ses yeux de faire planer sur
le monde la menace d'un retour à l'âge
de l'impérialisme a-t-il dit ce qui a
une expression qu'on a entendu aussi
chez olafs le chancelier allemand à la
même tribune il a au retour des colonies
à même dit Emmanuel Macron puisque ça
ouvre la voie selon lui à d'autres
guerres d'annexion peut-être en Europe
mais peut-être demain aussi en Afrique
en Asie en Amérique latine alors
effectivement il y avait ce ton qui
était qui était offensif martial
pourquoi ce changement de temps et bien
sûr une question de contexte immédiat la
déclaration de Vladimir Poutine qui
n'était pas connue mais qui était
attendu par Emmanuel Macron au moment où
il s'est exprimé il y a eu l'annonce de
la tenue de ces référendums dans ces
républiques autoproclamés du dombasia
les inquiétudes autour de la centrale
nucléaire de zapporisia ou il y a encore
la récente convocation de l'ambassadeur
de France à Moscou pour par les
autorités russes pour lui signifier que
que Moscou y est d'un très mauvais œil
les livraison d'armes de Paris à Kiev
mais la vérité en fait c'est que ce
discours s'adressait pas vraiment
une justification et un avertissement
une justification qui était plutôt
destinée à tous les pays comme l'Ukraine
certains pays d'Europe orientale mais
aussi certains de nos alliés qui
trouvent la France ou qui trouvait la
France parfois trop de diplomatiques
avec la lumière Poutine qui reprochait
par exemple à Emmanuel Macron d'avoir
maintenu le fil du dialogue coûte que
coûte avec le maître du Kremlin sans
jamais avoir obtenu de gages ou de
véritables signaux de la part de
Vladimir Poutine alors la fermeté hier
du président c'était destiné à les
rassurer sur la forme parce que sur le
four il compte pas changer de ligne il a
prévenu d'ailleurs qui maintiendrait le
dialogue avec le maître du Kremlin donc
ça c'est la justification
l'avertissement il était en revanche
destiné aux autres c'est-à-dire tous les
autres pays qui se sont bien gardés
d'intervenir ne serait-ce que en paroles
dans le conflit ce réfugiant dans une
forme de neutralité ou de non-alignement
Emmanuel macrony mais c'est pas ça non
alignement d'alignement c'est la paix
c'est pas de laisser faire la guerre on
sait le son qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure je veux dire c'est c'est ça
c'est c'est cette idée cette idée là ce
genre de discours ce qu'on peut se
demander c'est ce ça peut avoir un effet
en fait sur la paix non évidemment parce
qu'on l'aide tout à l'heure ça ne se
fait pas à l'ONU ça ça serait trop beau
ça se fait pas la tribune et puis en
plus le chef de l'État du point de vue
de la France en tout cas fixé une
feuille de route qui est à peu près de
ce que j'ai compris la même que Joe
Biden puisqu'il parle d'intégrité joiden
Emmanuel Macron parlait de l'Ukraine
dans ses frontières donc on imagine que
c'est les frontières d'avoir le conflit
il a dit que la paix ne se ferait que si
l'Ukraine le voulait et que si la Russie
l'acceptait pour l'instant on en est
encore loin petit message d'ignation de
la régie est-ce qu'on a le premier
extrait d'Emmanuel Macron
voilà j'aimerais bien qu'on l'entende
quand même parce que il est vraiment
intéressant sur la la tonalité du
discours écoutez
nous avons aujourd'hui à faire un choix
simple au fond
celui de la guerre ou de la paix
le 24 février dernier la Russie membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité à rompu
par un acte d'agression d'invasion et
d'annexion notre sécurité collective
elle a délibérément violé la Charte des
Nations Unies et le principe d'égalité
souveraine des états
intéressants
dans ce discours d'Emmanuel Macron deux
éléments que je soulignerais c'est la
première c'est que il s'adresse au pays
qui se cache derrière la fosse
neutralité je pense que c'est important
à voir parce que effectivement la guerre
qui se passe sur le territoire ukrainien
certes c'est la guerre un peu de la de
pays des libertés contre les pays de
dictatures bon globalement si on prend
le cadre de la guerre hybride et
deuxième chose c'est que ma grande parle
souvent de nous quand on lui dit que
nous sommes attaqués donc on justement
ils mettent la dimension
hors l'Ukraine mais pareil dans le camp
de pays qui se situe dans la démocratie
donc pour nous pour les Ukrainiens on le
ressent comme une signe de solidarité
dans le discours vous parliez de la
deuxième catégorie et le président
Macron a bien signalé les pays non
alignés les pays non alignés c'est un
groupe extrêmement puissant aux Nations
Unies qui datent de l'époque de la
guerre froide non online sont les
appelle les names nom de movement qui
est extrêmement puissant et là ce qui
leur reproche en fait c'est de rester
groupé dans cette neutralité alors qu'on
a complètement changé d'époque on peut
peut-être citer les plus importantes par
exemple était le leader aux Nations
Unies en tout cas mais c'est tous les
pays j'allais dire ce qu'on appelait les
pays du tiers-monde globalement
c'est être complice c'est ça exactement
il dit ne vous trompez pas et je pense
que ce qui va être extrêmement
intéressant c'est le discours que nous
ne verrons pas là parce qu'il y a pas
encore eu lieu c'est le président
zeninski qui va s'adresser à l'Assemblée
parce que connaissant un peu l'hémicycle
si vous voulez qui va être présent et
qu'elle va être la réaction à la fin du
discours extrêmement important parce que
la on se souviendra en 2003 de Dominique
de Villepin qui intervenait c'était au
Conseil de sécurité c'était pas
l'assemblée générale pour former le
choix de la France de ne pas intervenir
il y a eu applaudissement à la fin et au
Conseil de sécurité c'était surprise
alors que là l'assemblée générale il y a
les 193 pays qui sont présentés est-ce
qu'ils vont applaudir
Macron c'était pas la prof qui était au
poste ça veut dire que c'est pas la tête
de liste ils ont mis un deuxième couteau
qui est le ministre qui est venu parce
que Poutine
au-delà du fait qu'il a peut-être autre
chose à faire n'allez pas se mouiller à
venir au à l'ONU où il risquait d'être
très isolé et donc on va voir là lorsque
le président zenki aura pris la parole
qu'elle va être la réaction de
l'Assemblée parce que là les caméras
vont numéroter tout le monde en disant
celui-là il est resté assis celui-là il
s'est levé celui-là il est parti tiens
là c'était le troisième couteau qui a
été mis et non le chef de délégation ça
je peux vous dire que ça va être scruté
et dans les jours qui viennent puisque
de lys reste de trois jours quand même
aux Nations Unies il peut y avoir une
dynamique ou pas dynamique et ça va être
intéressant à la fois d'écouter le
discours et de voir ce qui va se passer
le lendemain parce que le président
Zelinski ça va être au milieu de la nuit
pour nous à peu près et alors il y a un
autre discours que qui était très
attendu et là c'était en cette fin
d'après-midi il y a une demi-heure à
l'heure où je vous parle c'est celui du
président américain Joe Biden je vous en
propose un extrait tout de suite
maintenant la Russie appelle davantage
de soldats pour rejoindre le combat et
le Kremlin essaye d'organiser un
référendum factice pour démembrer le
territoire ukrainien
c'est une violation flagrante de la
Charte des Nations Unies il faut voir
ses actions outrageantes pour ce
qu'elles sont Poutine dit que c'est
parce que la Russie était menacée mais
personne n'a jamais menacé la Russie
personne d'autre que la Russie n'a
cherché le conflit
[Musique]
cette guerre visa anéantir le droit de
l'Ukraine a existé en tant qu'État tout
simplement et le droit de l'Ukraine a
existé en tant que peuple
ou que vous soyez ou que vous viviez
quel que soit vos convictions cela ne
devrait pas cela devrait suffire à nous
faire frissonner
Patricia lemonnière ce discours il était
très attendu comment vous l'analysez
alors il était très attendu il est pas
c'est pas un discours comme le président
Macron qui s'emport qui qui parle avec
les mains etc c'est un discours plus
posé néanmoins néanmoins Joe byden
emploi des mots forts il parle
effectivement d'un fois que l'Ukraine
doit conserver son intégrité
territoriale c'est c'est très important
il parle aussi de la rupture qui a
produite la Russie en ne respectant pas
les chartes de l'ONU aussi moment
important et enfin il dit une autre
chose que la Russie n'a jamais été
menacé et ça souvenez-vous dans le
discours de Vladimir Poutine Vladimir
Poutine dit que c'est l'Europe et
l'Occident qui a menacé là aussi c'est
donc parce qu'il est menacé qu'il
finalement se défend et c'est là où on
voit qu'il y a un changement de discours
chez poutinho il y a une autre histoire
qui nous est racontée début de
l'histoire c'était on pas libérer ce
pays des nazéifiés et maintenant on doit
se défendre parce que nous sommes
attaqués nouvelle histoire nouveau
discours et Joe Biden répond mot à mot à
ce discours en faisant appel comme le
président Macron a aux autres pays dont
vous avez tous parlé les ce qu'on
appelle les non alignés mais je crois
qu'ils le font avec un autre esprit que
les non alignés le font parce qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui le monde se
fracture et qu'il y a un
antioxydantalisme qui grimpe alimentée
par la Russie par la Chine et c'est très
important de leur temps de la main et de
les ramener alors il y a deux autres
aspects moi j'aime bien voilà charpenter
un peu nos débats sur lesquels on va on
va passer du temps c'est à la fois les
les référendums d'annexion à annoncé par
la hypothing et évidemment la menace
nucléaire vous avez déjà parlé un
instant mais je voudrais avant de parler
des référendum vous redonner la parole
sur un autre aspect du discours de de
Joe Biden il a dit souhaité une réforme
du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU en
augmentant le nombre de ses membres
évidemment on imagine qu'en creux ça
affaiblirait la Russie la Chine bon la
France et la France c'est pas faux mais
comment est-ce que c'est possible est-ce
que c'est réaliste ça commence à marche
vous qui connaissez par cœur le
fonctionnement le président Macron a
fait la même remarque il a souhaité que
ce alors ça fait des années que la
réforme est sur la table tout le monde
est d'accord quasiment qu'il faut
élargir le gros problème c'est en
Afrique quel pays en Asie quel pays en
Afrique vous avez une Nigéria d'élargir
le le Conseil
on pense aux membres permanents et on
pense de cinq
à dix membre permanents et par exemple
que chacun des continents est un membre
en plus par exemple l'Afrique alors
est-ce que ça va être le Nigéria
l'Afrique du Sud
l'Éthiopie et en Asie est-ce que ça va
être l'Inde le Japon en fait depuis des
années ça ne progresse pas parce qu'ils
se mettent pas d'accord tout bêtement et
alors il faut reconnaître que ceux qui
sont conseil joue là-dessus mais mais en
gros tout le monde dit oui il faut
l'élargir mais maintenant faites vos
choix
oui mais il y a un moment alors il y a
eu des tas de méthodes qui ont été
utilisés avec des moi je l'ai vu avec
des votes successifs pour y arriver puis
à la fin au blocage on y arrive pas
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à désigner les
pays qui devraient rentrer comme membre
permanent la deuxième pardon la deuxième
réforme la présenter uniquement par le
président français c'est le droit de
veto l'impossibilité d'utiliser le droit
de veto lorsqu'il y a massacre voilà
alors comme promis les référendum
d'anix-seine d'annexion pardon c'est une
autre annonce du discours du président
russe et je propose à Alexandre Poussard
2 nous rejoindre bonsoir Alexandre
bienvenue sur ce plateau donc des
référendum organisés annoncés par
Vladimir Poutine dans quatre régions de
l'est de l'Ukraine en vue de les
intégrer à la Fédération de de Russie
alors on va déjà être très pédago quel
territoire sont concernés alors très
concrètement ces référendum vont avoir
lieu dans quatre régions de l'Ukraine
d'abord les régions du Logan
qui forme le Dombas et dossier dans ces
régions en 2014 que les séparatistes
prorus avaient proclamé des républicains
de séparatistes sur les territoires
qu'ils contrôlaient ensuite les deux
autres régions où vont avoir lieu ses
référendum d'intégration à la Russie
bien ce sont les régions de zaporigia et
de Carson occupé actuellement par
l'armée russe et cette annonce des
référendums qui sont souvent pilotés par
Vladimir Poutine pour annexer ses
régions et bien Vladimir Poutine il
soutient officiellement très fortement
l'organisation de ces scrutins et la
bonne tenue du scrutin on va l'écouter
je souligne que nous ferons tout pour
garantir des conditions sûrs pour les
référendum afin que les gens puissent
exprimer leur volonté et nous
soutiendrons la décision sur leur avenir
prise par la majorité des habitants des
républiques populaires de Donetsk et de
Louhansk et des régions de zaporigia et
Carson
voilà Thomas derrière l'annonce de ces
référendum de ces scrutins et bien il y
a une réalité militaire ces régions qui
sont revendiquées par la Russie elles
correspondent aux territoires qui sont
encore occupés actuellement par l'armée
russe sauf une partie du don-basse et
cette annonce est bien elle a lieu dans
le contexte de la contre-offensive de
l'Ukraine qui reprend du terrain sur
certains territoires notamment dans la
zone entre carquive et le Dombas donc
ces référendum pour Vladimir Poutine
c'est une manière de sauver les meubles
de sauver les territoires
occupés et puis aussi d'adresser une
nouvelle menace à l'Ukraine et à
l'Occident car selon le Kremlin et bien
après un probable oui assez référendum à
l'intégration de ces territoires dans la
Fédération de Russie ça voudrait dire
que la guerre se déroulera désormais sur
le territoire russe et regardez ce qu'a
dit Dimitri Medvedev le numéro 2 du
Conseil de sécurité russe ancien
président russe après l'annonce de ces
référendums je le cite empiété sur sur
le territoire de la Russie est un crime
et si elle est commis cela vous permet
d'utiliser toutes les forces de légitime
défense autrement dit l'arme atomique on
peut dire que c'est pas une première et
non on peut finir en disant que cette
technique du référendum elle a déjà été
utilisée par Vladimir Poutine en 2014
pour annexer la Crimée à ce moment-là un
référendum avait été organisé à la
va-vite la Crimée déclarée proclamée et
bien parti du territoire russe et cette
annexion est bien elle n'a toujours pas
été reconnue par la majorité de la
communauté internationale merci
Alexandre pour toutes ces explications à
la laser il faut peut-être nous dire
comment ça peut se passer c'est à dire
que on imagine un référendum organisé
dans ces dans ces territoires votre sous
contrainte c'est une évidence c'est plus
compliqué que ça pour moi déjà c'est pas
du tout les référendum le mot employé en
fait
il faut pas le reprendre je pense qu'il
faut pas le reprendre parce que c'est
même pas la consultation populaire vu
que ça se passe sur le ménage des armes
donc
partout dans le monde entier les tous
les témoignages tous les démarches qui
sont fait sous menaces d'armes ne sont
pas reconnus c'est une imitation de
référendum imitation de consultation
quand vous voulez mais c'est pas du tout
le référendum c'est point numéro 1
numéro 2 c'est que effectivement les
gens qui sont
nés là-bas qui peuvent voter ils sont en
grande majorité partie donc ceux qui
sont restés c'est souvent ceux qui n'ont
pas pu laisser les parents
âgés ou étaient empêché autrement est-ce
qu'ils vont s'exprimer librement bien
sûr que non mais il y a quand même
pardon nous interrompre une population
russophone aussi dans certaines de ces
régions il faut pas confondre les
risques fondent et les Russes filent il
y a les gens qui s'expriment heureuse
parce qu'ils ont l'habitude de le faire
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'ils sont
admiratifs de l'État russe
despotique qu'ils veulent faire partie
de la Russie de Poutine et même s'ils
ont des origines russes quelquefois il
se bat à l'arme à la main pour le crâne
parce que le grain c'est la terre de
liberté on n'est pas parfait on a
beaucoup de défauts mais c'est le pays
libre il démocratique donc le clivage ne
se passe pas sur les questions de langue
et même pas sur le partenaires c'est les
rapports à la liberté c'est très
important à voir justement en parlant de
ces faux référendum et donc comment ça
va se passer juridiquement ça change
rien du tout parce que reste toujours
nos territoires occupés temporairement
occupé
on a le droit de les reprendre mais
l'étirement parce que c'est notaire tout
simplement le récit de Poutine au bon il
fait adresser mais pourquoi il faut
l'écouter et prendre en compte moi je
vais pas d'intérêt donc
en fait je ne pense pas que ça changera
grand chose à part le rhétorique alors
le rhétorique ça va il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui vont parler mais après
soviétique de lancer des appels par des
peuples opprimés des partis communistes
locaux pour appeler le grand frère russe
à la rescousse là c'est globalement ce
qui est en train de se passer mais
d'ailleurs le président Poutine ne fait
que répondre à une demande des des
locaux des locaux qui ont été mis en
place c'est la troisième fois que les
dates change ça devait être début
septembre dès la taxe a été repoussée à
novembre et là d'un seul coup c'est
proposé pour la semaine prochaine c'est
un petit peu en catastrophe pour
transformer en terre russe et puis avoir
la menace qui a proférée et mettre
vellef dans la bouche maintenant je
voudrais juste rappeler que la Crimée
depuis 2015 est considérée comme tel
russe elle a été attaquée et il y a pas
eu d'escalade donc si vous voulez tout
ça entre le langage ferme et la réalité
des choses il y a quand même une marge
Patricia comment l'analyse c'est quand
même un grand supplémentaire alors il
faut rester peut-être serein face à
cette menace mais c'est un cran
supplémentaire dans la dans cette menace
nucléaire brandie
on a eu le discours vis-à-vis des Russes
puis aussi le discours la visite
l'Occident il invoque le changement de
doctrine qui a eu dans les années 2020
si je ne me trompe pas avec l'idée que
si la Russie était menacée l'État russe
était menacé et bien il pouvait se
défendre avec tous les moyens à sa
disposition alors là il peut considérer
effectivement que s'il y a des attaques
sur les Oblates les fameux homblastes
qui sont une partie des ebelins d'excès
et bien là ça sera l'État russe qui sera
menacé et donc là il pourra répondre par
toutes les armes qui sont à la à sa
merci dont les armes nucléaires dont
nous reparlerons peut-être tactique ou
autre mais ça c'est vis-à-vis des
opinions je crois occidentales pour le
coup il a envie chaque fois de nous
faire peur de nous faire peur de nous
diviser et ça marche parce qu'on
n'arrête pas d'en parler de cette menace
nucléaire donc c'est formidable pour lui
c'est c'est ça fait du buzz
regardez je peux d'autant que c'est vous
déjà qui m'avez menacé a-t-il dit au
début de ton discours et là maintenant
russe et bien ces détails qui menaçaient
et donc et chaque fois il fait aboyer
autour de lui effectivement les gens qui
sont payés pour ça dont Metz dans qui se
contrefait excusez-moi du terme en temps
normal de mettre le DAF mais il
l'utilise toujours pour ce genre de
choses et puis aussi l'expert calmer
quand même un peu c'est dur qui sont
toujours en revient jusqu'à
usage interne à des situations
mais je vais je vais vous proposer un
autre extrait de son discours justement
sur cette menace nucléaire voici les
termes employés par le président russe
je tiens à vous rappeler que notre pays
dispose également de diverses armes de
destruction et à certains égards elles
sont même plus modernes que celles des
pays de l'OTAN s'il y a une menace pour
l'intégrité territoriale de notre pays
afin de protéger la Russie notre peuple
nous utiliserons certainement tous les
moyens à notre disposition
ce n'est pas du bluff il termine comme
ça oui mais chaque fois vous noterez
mais le vedf lui ne cite jamais le
nucléaire jamais il parle des armes
puissantes etc et ça leur permet de
retourner en disant vous voyez bien que
la menace elle est de l'autre côté la
menace nucléaire puisque c'est vous qui
en parlez nous on n'a pas le tous donc
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
il joue sur nos peurs et et nos peurs
vont plus loin que ça pardonnez-moi mais
je
j'interviens sur beaucoup de plateau
télévisés on mélange le nucléaire civil
nucléaire militaire le tactique et le
stratégique on mélange tout ça eux n'en
parle pas il parle d'une graduation
d'utilisation des armes et puis il
laisse nos fantasmes tournés autour de
ça
fantasmes exactement vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse oui parfaitement je
suis d'accord parce que c'est exactement
ça qu'ils veulent c'est lancer la peur
qui se reproduit que se nourrit de ses
propres récides ses propres répétitions
mais effectivement eux ils restent très
très prud dans les expressions parce que
effectivement être le deuxième pays du
monde qui emploie alarme nucléaire quoi
qu'il arrive c'est une responsabilité
immense même par rapport à tout ce
qu'ils ont fait déjà une crème tous les
crimes des guerres qui étaient commises
par l'armée russe tous les morts des
civils tous les autres sociétés qui
étaient faites c'est quand même une
grade très importante et y compris pour
leur propre population parce que dire
que je parle les Ukrainiens dans nos
aiment pas elles veulent pas faire le
même état que nous c'est une chose mais
nous avons employé l'arme nucléaire
contre même l'Ukraine je sais pas la
Chine qui vous voulez ça c'est quand
même tout à fait autre responsabilité
collective et je ne suis pas sûr que la
Russie la charge a rappelé dans son
discours qui est impossible je cite il
est impossible de gagner une guerre
nucléaire mais sur oui mais alors
on va rentrer dans le détail des armes
ce que vous vous dites qu'on mélange un
peu tout est-ce qu'il y a des armes
nucléaires
comment je peux dire ça d'utilisation
réduite vous voyez ce que je veux dire
sur le terrain tout de suite
aux champignons nucléaires qui détruit
tout alors je vais vous jouer le général
de Gaulle arrêtez de m'emmerder avec ça
le nucléaire c'est le nucléaire d'accord
terminé non mais c'est ça si vous voulez
alors le nucléaire tactique au
passage on souligne que la France n'en a
plus elle l'a fait à un moment il
s'était une erreur elle a fait une
erreur en ayant une émission plutôt
Hadès et cetera qui normalement était la
dernière frappe d'avertissement avant
etc le nucléaire reste le nucléaire et
le jour où on emploie le nucléaire on
change de dimension la roche lui-même a
dit écoutez l'emploi de l'harmonicaire
c'est la planète est rasée donc je crois
qu'il faut bien c'est le problème de la
dissuasion
ça paraît c'est compliqué mais c'est une
arme de non-emploi et ce qui permet
d'ailleurs au passage aux Russes de
faire ce qu'ils font parce que eux sont
protégés par l'arme nucléaire parce que
le temps tout va bien se garder
d'attaquer la Russie compte tenu de et à
l'inverse la chose est la même pour nous
Poutine c'est très bien qui ne franchira
pas la ligne rouge de la frontière de
l'OTAN parce que le temps dispose de
l'arme nucléaire donc ça peut paraître
un peu idiot et de dire ben pourquoi il
y a 5000 armes après tout si c'est pour
pas s'en servir mais oui mais parce
qu'il y a une course aux armements et
pour montrer qu'on était plus crédible
que l'autre mais je pense que vraiment
le nucléaire reste le nucléaire et
est-ce qu'on a une idée de l'état dans
lequel se trouve l'arsenal nucléaire
militaire russe l'état d'alerte ou
l'état
aujourd'hui on le sait parce que vous
savez qu'il y a quatre graduations dans
l'état d'alerte je sais pas s'il
fonctionne bien ou pas mais dans l'état
d'alerte et peu de temps après le début
de l'attaque il a fait mettre à l'état 2
et la connaissance qu'on a aujourd'hui
du sujet c'est qu'ils sont pas passés à
l'état 3 sont toujours à l'état d'eux
donc il y a deux états supérieurs ce qui
avait d'inquiétant
a été le président Biden qui a trois
jours je crois trois jours a dit ne
lutte ne le faites pas ne le faites pas
ne le faites pas par trois fois en
parlant à Poutine en lui disant
n'utilisez pas l'arme nucléaire ça veut
dire qu'il avait quand même c'est plus
dans la psychologie de Poutine vous
voyez Poutine étant acculé pourrait
faire une bêtise comme on pensait le 23
février qui ferait jamais la bêtise
d'attaquer bah si il l'a fait bon il
pourrait faire ça mais aujourd'hui la
certitude qu'on a c'est qui sont
toujours au stade 2 et que donc on n'a
pas grimpé depuis le début de la guerre
parce que ça rejoint un peu ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure Patricia lemener
vous nous dites il est il est dans un
coin il est il a besoin d'en sortir
alors je dis pas que l'arme nucléaire
l'usage de l'arme nucléaire peut peut
être le moyen d'en sortir mais quand on
est à ce point acculé qu'est-ce qui peut
se passer ça ça nourrit aussi
l'inquiétude alors il y a pas de risque
zéro ça serait complètement
idiot de dire non il ne l'utilisera
jamais il n'y a pas de risque zéro mais
disons que je crois que aujourd'hui on
peut dire qu'il essaie de sortir de
cette passe difficile en utilisant en
par derrière cette possibilité qui n'a
parce que effectivement on le sait il
est à peu près 1000 il a 5000 et
quelques ogives nucléaire il y en a 1000
qui seraient obsolète bon mais qu'est-ce
qu'il va le faire il va nous faire
sauter la planète avec ses 5000 alors il
y a des fameuses pour répondre à votre
question les fameuses tactiques
stratégiques etc qui sera efficace sur
20 km mais à partir du moment où vous
utilisez une arme nucléaire même que sur
20 km vous franchissez comme vous le
dites quelque chose qui est impensable
c'est-à-dire vous vous violez un accord
terrestre j'ai envie de dire mondial et
dans ce cas là vous devenez le plus
grand des Parisiens et vous ouvrez la
porte sur l'inconnu je ne crois pas
qu'il en soit là aujourd'hui je ne crois
pas mais le risque zéro n'existe pas il
faut se préparer de toute façon
on parlait des hypothèses présentées par
les Américains les états majeurs ils
préparent toutes les hypothèses a pris
la pire bien sûr c'est normal bien sûr
alors on est sur la l'aspect militaire
et on va revenir à la situation
militaire sur le terrain en
Ukraine je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait du discours du porte-parole de
la Commission européenne toujours à
l'ONU
le discours du président Poutine et les
annonces qu'il a fait à la fois sur ses
référendum et sur la mobilisation
partielle c'est juste une autre preuve
de Poutine qu'il n'est pas intéressé par
la paix qu'il est intéressé par
l'escalade de sa guerre c'est aussi un
autre signe de son désarroi face à la
façon dont son agression se déroule
contre l'Ukraine
is going
alors effectivement à la laservée on
parle souvent de de ce que l'hiver va
changer dans dans les zones de combat
c'est pas encore l'hiver en Ukraine donc
il y a encore quelques semaines de
combat qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire de
ça quelques semaines c'est sûr mais il
faut aussi savoir que nos hivers sonnent
rude normalement on a le climat
continental ça signifie que en hiver on
peut avoir facilement en moins de 20
moins de 15 donc ça change la situation
sur le champ de bataille
après je sais que c'est pour ça aussi
que la l'offensif continue c'est que ce
qui explique nos experts militaires
parce que justement on veut pas rentrer
dans les saisons de pluie c'est bientôt
c'est c'est octobre novembre et qui qui
vraiment complique beaucoup les
l'utilisation de l'équipement militaire
donc c'est surtout ça
c'est la pluie
à l'automne et au printemps et la boue
et vraiment un phénomène en béton pour
les franchissements de rivière bien sûr
parce qu'elles deviennent très large et
impraticables et les les engins blindés
ont du mal à se mouvoir il y a quel
souvenir des images deuxième guerre
mondiale avec l'armée russe l'armée
allemande pardon qui avait eu de grandes
difficultés donc c'est plus ça c'est
pour ça que la pression il y a une sorte
de course contre la montre complètement
notamment de la part des Ukrainiens qui
accélère pour prendre de regagner des
territoires éventuellement avant quoi
les courses contre la menthe sont au
nord et au sud au nord parce qu'il faut
exploiter au maximum l'offensive qui a
été réussite mais qui ralentit beaucoup
maintenant quand même parce que sur la
durée c'est compliqué à mener et dans le
sud où c'est l'étouffement de l'armée
russe c'est une méthode complètement
différente aller vite au nord et
étouffer l'armée russe mais là aussi il
faudrait qu'elle l'armée russe d'une
certaine façon baisse les armes parce
que le problème c'est que le Nieppe
étant quasiment impraticable pour les
Russes même les pontons sont tirés donc
ils ont de moins dans moins de
ravitaillement munitions nourriture tout
bêtement et donc le but c'est en fait de
faire prisonnier une armée russe ce qui
serait psychologiquement vous imaginez
le président Poutine il y a 20 000
hommes à peu près donc il y aura
peut-être pas 20000 prisonniers mais
d'ailleurs dans les lois que le
président Poutine a fait passer en même
temps que la mobilisation il a fait une
loi sur les déserteurs sur ceux qui se
rendaient et avec en élevant
considérablement les peines contre sa
prouve bien qu'il y a des versions au
passage bien sûr évidemment Patricia
lemonnière on parle de cette poche là
donc il y a 20 000 soldats russes c'est
ça qui sont encerclés ça c'est peut-être
le le l'objectif le plus atteignable par
l'armée ukrainienne avant c'est plus
dont on parle c'est d'autant plus
difficile en même temps que c'est une
région de plaine moi j'étais dans le
Dombas etc c'est une région complètement
différente là c'est une région de plaine
donc se battre est beaucoup plus
difficile parce qu'on avance à découvert
quand même donc c'est beaucoup plus
complexe et l'idée effectivement c'est
de les fermer de les prendre par
l'arrière et de et de le bloquer la
possibilité de retrait peut-être en
laissant un petit couloir pour qu'il se
retire mais comme vous le dites mais ce
n'est pas tout la région de Kerson c'est
une poche c'est une poche qui est très
précise que les Ukrainiens voudraient
prendre parce que c'est très intéressant
par rapport au fleuve et puis surtout
moralement par rapport à la région de
Kerson c'est un sacré coup sur la tête
donc c'est important on sait pas si ils
vont pouvoir le faire avant justement
les pluies après reste l'hiver et
l'hiver par contre je peux vous dire
qu'on se bat parce que pour avoir été en
janvier février dans le Dombas là il y a
pas de problème pour faire avancer
Comment le peuple ukrainien se prépare à
l'hiver c'est une guerre qui dure depuis
plus de 7 mois maintenant il y a il y a
toujours cette mobilisation dont on a
parlé cet esprit patriotique dont on a
parlé c'est toujours aussi présent c'est
toujours où il y a une lassitude qui
commence à gagner ça non non justement
comme on n'a pas de choix on doit se
défendre les populations des très
mobilisée derrière l'armée il y a
beaucoup d'aide à l'armée il y a
beaucoup de cagnottes qui circulent pour
acheter ça aussi pour l'armée ukrainien
il y a beaucoup de gens qui amènent vers
la ligne de front les différents aides
possibles impossible donc pour l'hiver
on comprend que ce sera pas facile parce
que comme j'ai dit le vert est froid
donc il y a les questions de chauffage
il y a la question de gaz de
l'électricité qui peut être endommagée
et coupé oui oui même on a vu déjà ce
que tu fais à zapporica donc voilà tous
les possibilités existent mais les gens
se préparent vous savez je rentre dès le
train j'étais pendant cinq jours à le
vivre on sait pas loin c'est à la
frontière mais quand même je peux dire
que je peux témoigner que l'ambiance
n'est pas disons inquiète les gens ne
sont pas paniqués ils sont conscients de
danger donc il y a pas d'illusion il y a
pas de personne ne prend à la légère
sokonovie c'est ce qu'on vit mais en
même temps les gens ne paniquent pas
donc ils disent qu'il faut se défendre
il faut se battre il faut rester serein
et bon la victoire soit sera en nous je
sais pas quand et pourquoi et pourtant
il y a eu beaucoup de morts oui bien sûr
allez il nous reste un peu moins de 5
minutes dernier chapitre et on va
s'appuyer sur une des réactions de cette
fin d'après-midi depuis l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies c'est celle
du président français après le discours
de Vladimir Poutine ce qu'on écoutait
tout à l'heure on le rappelle c'était
avant donc là c'était Emmanuel Macron il
y a quelques minutes
aujourd'hui
ce à quoi j'appelle la Russie au premier
chef et tous c'est que nous mettions
tous évidemment le cesser le feu et la
paix et c'est que tout le monde puisse
mettre maintenant le maximum de pression
sur le président Poutine pour qu'il
cesse cette guerre qui n'a plus aucun
sens et je me félicite des déclarations
récentes du président chinois du Premier
ministre indien et je souhaite que dans
la lignée de ce que j'ai pu exprimer
hier à la tribune de l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies nous
puissions nous unir et progressivement
être de plus en plus nombreux
pour rappeler au cessez-le-feu et à la
paix qui est la seule voie acceptable
dans ce conflit et je pense que tout
escalade même verbal ne mène à rien
Patricia lemonnière effectivement le
cesser le feu c'est un terme qui a été
employé par un ministre chinois
aujourd'hui je voudrais revenir une
semaine en arrière cette rencontre qui a
eu lieu en Ouzbékistan est-ce qu'on sait
ce qui s'est dit entre civil pin le
président chinois et Vladimir Poutine
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de pression
mise par le président chinois sur son
homologue c'est pas en détail ce qui
s'est dit mais on a vu toute tout ce qui
était de la du gestuelle et de
l'apparence avec ce côté de de côté de
demande de Poutine et ce côté un peu
seniorial du président chinois et seul
les mots prononcés par le porte-parole
chinois aujourd'hui sont très importants
et ce qui était cette réunion à sa
marque qui aussi était très important
c'est la position indienne les Indiens
sont en train d'évoluer et comme on va
voir bien besoin de quelqu'un qui joue
les entremetteurs les facilitateurs je
ne pense pas que ça puisse être la
France parce qu'on est trop impliqués on
livre des armes justement je ne pense
pas que ça peut être la Chine parce que
quoi qu'on en dise elle fait son petit
business ça pourrait être l'Inde
justement et ça peut pas être de gain
non plus parce qu'il est un peu trop
pour vous est-ce qu'ils pour un peu
compter sur l'Inde qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez oui bien sûr il a il a il avait
dit il a dit que l'heure n'était pas à
la guerre
la réunion de Samarcande est très très
intéressante le président cgping est
allé au Kazakhstan avant d'aller à
saint-marcande dans le Kazakhstan c'est
le pays de la région qui applique
l'embargo européen malgré la pression de
de Poutine ensuite le président anxie
n'était pas présent sur la photo finale
donc il a pas voulu se mettre là-dedans
en même temps cette région qui l'Asie
centrale qui était vraiment les les Féo
de la Russie le Kirghizistan et le
Tadjikistan commencent à se battre sans
que la Russie soit au courant le
président Poutine a appris pendant la
réunion c'était inimaginable il y a
quelques années donc je pense qui donc
mesure son aperçus comme un pardon de un
moment finalement de la photo de famille
de soutien à Vladimir Poutine c'est
plutôt en creux un affaiblissement
complètement c'est ce qu'il espérait un
regroupement et au contraire il est très
isolé et je répète j'attends de voir
l'assemblée générale pour voir s'il sera
encore plus isolé ce sera pour cette
nuit merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat et à bientôt évidemment sur sur
public